you're falling in love with yourself
I know you hate to admit it
there's a lot of other people you could
be falling in love with but you're
choosing you Tia Morris ready for her
next chapter following the news of her
divorce people like you they like you if
they don't they don't but just just be
you nearly a week after the actress
announced the end of her 14-year
marriage to Corey Hardrick she hopped
online to thank people for their support
writing in part quote every book starts
with a dedication page and this one's
dedicated to you my friends family and
Community where I come from and how my
parents raised us it's about your
integrity and it's about your character
and it's about who you are as a person
Tia says the outpouring of love has been
so encouraging and humbling and adds
quote new book first chapter to follow
love Tia I feel you know grateful
despite citing irreconcilable
differences as the reason behind their
split it seems the former couple is
still on good terms the actor commented
on her post with a red heart emoji and
tia responded I love you so they have
this expectation going into marriage
that everything is going to be perfect
nothing is perfect but perhaps Tia's
most powerful message post split this
video where she writes this chapter of
my life is called my turn
you're falling in love with yourself
I know you hate to admit it
there's a lot of other people you could
be falling in love with
but you're choosing you
being in control
of what I want to do and what I love to
do and knowing that I have that control
knowing that you can do whatever you put
your mind to and I've proven that to
myself over and over and over again Tia
and Corey split comes just one week
after she gushed to E.T about her
family's summer vacation but to be in
Italy with again with our children and
our husbands it was just so amazing and
surreal surreal and just so wonderful
the two share two kiddos together
eleven-year-old son cree and
four-year-old daughter Cairo and when it
comes to their little ones Tia insists
they'll maintain a friendship as they
co-parent family is so important to me
and in the wake of the split seems Tia's
keeping her spirits High by spending
time with her kids on Monday she shared
these sweet pics writing alongside it
the beach is my happy place maybe it'll
be Kairos too I know that my daughter is
not a woman yet Cairo but she pushes me
to be better she's only four years old
I'm a strong believer that children
learn through observation
she's going to learn and see how I
navigate through this world
and so she motivates me to make the
right decisions no matter what those
decisions are whether they're in
relationships whether they're with your
job your career she really does she's an
extension of who I am
[Music]
thank you